where is this [ __ ] freezer around
here right down here so this is the
frozen bit here
what's that frozen avocado are we not in
Florida
and you can't make fresh avocado
there this is [ __ ] up man walking Wow
Wow
when was the last time you were in here
I come in here once a week at least and
I'm still kind of you know just kind of
look around or whatever what is this
Wow oh man look at that the waters gone
slimy and you come in here once a week
yeah what is that
[Music]
oh boy
okay how what is that pina colada pina
colada
why it's like that I have no idea it's
best that it's off its bubbling oh man
that's terrible [ __ ] trash please trash
James
trash please now pina colada right down
the drain by the bucketload in the
walk-in fridge I mean who in the hell up
race like this Gordon this is chef Ben's
job is the Executive Chef it's the
executive chef and you've made him that
executive chef right
sure I did how'd you feel now what's
that tuna burger that's from the burger
yes it is oh my god seriously bacon it's
gone it's off fresh produce on top of
all produce moldy and this one ribeye
ribeye defrosting what is this those are
the smoked grilled chicken wings before
they go onto the char grill oh and what
is in this one you are kidding me
so underneath in that buckets was cooked
product cooks the chicken and on top of
it is what it's rough raw chicken on top
of cooked chicken I had them for lunch
I am at a [ __ ] loss you're the best
way out of this
it's just shut the place down not an
option for me what's that in there Ben
there's a marinated chicken wings yeah
to be smoked underneath next box
those are smoked rule number [ __ ] one
Ben I know chef I didn't do it
you know I turn my back for a minute and
this is the kind of [ __ ] that happens I
walked in and it was bedlam
[Music]
he's telling me this is your fault
you've got no idea I am at a absolute
[ __ ] loss I can't work like this this
is huge
you now are running a restaurant
cross-contaminated